&gt;&gt; Remember that this first equation, y equals Ax squared plus bx plus C, is the
equation of a problem written in standard form. Because this contains two
variables, x and y, we can use it to graph points on a two dimensional. Plane.
For any value of x that we might want to consider, we can come up with a
corresponding value for y. And then, of course, plot that point on our plane. We
can't do that with this equation over here. Because there is no variable on the
left side. The only variable in the quadratic equation is x. So clearly, the
equation of parabola relates y to x. Whereas, the quadratic equation does not.
However, the quadratic equation is very powerful and useful for us in it's own
ways. It gives us a very straightforward way for finding the x-coordinates of
the x-intercepts of the parabola that it corresponds to. And of course, we could
find that equation, the equation of the parabola, by replacing the zero with y
again. The other thing that's very useful about a quadratic equation is that it
can actually be solved. Because we have one variable x in this equation and
there's only one equation, we can isolate x and find some number of values that
it needs to equal in order to make this equation true. So the equation of a
parabola can yield a graph, A quadratic equation can yield solutions. For values
of x, that tell us a lot about these graphs of parabolas. I know this is a
really subtle distinction, so if this seems a little bit confusing at all, that
makes perfect sense. I myself messed this up several times. Several crucial
times, before I really got the difference, so just keep reminding yourself of
the distinction, and when we use each one.